a little streaky
[Music]
my daughter Caitlyn reached out to me
with a great idea that I would apply
makeup to her face she sent me a couple
of pictures with some options and this
is what I chose I've never put makeup on
anybody or anything before and I think
I'm ready I thought I'd pick out my
favorite pair of glasses that made me
look like a makeup artist okay on my
scale of one to ten
where is your confidence level at
negative four
I'm gonna start with this is called
I forget
but I'm gonna put it on her face like
this
now I'm not going to use a brush because
I have hands like a baby I don't think
you should be advertising it and they're
soft
your skin sauce
oh yeah look at that that's perfect I'm
gonna get in there well I will say that
under the chin is a little darker than
the side of your face
I don't know how even I'm gonna make
this first round but I
oh my gosh
do your nose
okay look I really think
we're gonna start a new makeup Trend
where one side of your face is darker
than the others it really seems to have
gotten so
sorry hello
it really seems to have gotten super
dark right under you
it doesn't go Lively okay
and I think I'm done okay
bass applied
and so I think what we're doing here is
I had to pick between one of these two
to which I thought went on First and I'm
gonna say this one just powder it up
Grill if face I thought girl was on like
a teeth thing unless it's all a finger
girl okay
it's dirty
it looks like you've been working like
in the coal mine or something but I'm
gonna make it better
I gotta go gold oh lordy oh look at that
look at that angles up a little bit like
that there you go
oh that says a little streaky
laughs
it's all right that's all right
okay yeah I couldn't see that side quite
as well so let me see if I can fix it no
with the highlighter okay
I actually think I'm pretty close let me
see again hold on it this thing's a
little more
yeah wow
and these are feeling a little okay
all right
I think I just went on your tongue on
that one listen how does it taste
[Music]
my daughter Caitlyn reached out to me
with a great idea that I would apply
makeup to her face she sent me a couple
of pictures with some options and this
is what I chose I've never put makeup on
anybody or anything before and I think
I'm ready
I've never put this on anyone anyone
more
is that how you put it on don't you do
this
you want me to do that what would you
prefer when I see women in traffic
putting on oh yeah they do it like that
okay
I heard that hit tooth
please open YouTube listen how does it
taste
I think I just went on your tongue on
that one
okay
oh my God there's another two shot all
right I'm gonna be more careful here
it looks a little mommy dearest okay now
mush them together
yo that's professional
this is gonna be my favorite okay ready
oh not yet hold on I know there's a
pencil that's lips
this feels Lippy okay
I'm right on there I can't feel how
wrong you are
I'm getting yeah this is takes a steady
hand Kate you're gonna stay still oh try
doing in a moving car
oh my lord it's a little higher than I
wanted to bed to be honest
English oh do we fear don't ever go to
the medical field
turkey face
I feel like I'm getting better as we go
this is not a good idea oh okay
I was trying to get it right up on the
edge
[Applause]
I look like a grandma who lost her
glasses I will say this looks a little
crisper
I thought maybe I should start putting
on the glasses that helped me see what
I'm doing okay now this is the one part
that I was nervous about because we're
putting eyelashes on which means I'm
gonna glue close to your eyeballs now
this is the one part that I was nervous
about because we're putting eyelashes on
which means I'm going to glue close to
your eyeballs
[Music]
good shout out to me with a great idea
that I would apply makeup to her face
she sent me a couple of pictures with
some options and this is what I chose
I've never put makeup on anybody or
anything before and I think I'm ready
I'm gonna start with the left eye which
looks like
green blue and purple let's start with
green I think I should do fingers and
not brush
Circle I think that's smarter don't put
my eye out please don't worry that's why
I'm using fingers instead of brush
I'm gonna use the brush
that's where the green is supposed to be
not as much on the nose but right in
there a little goes a long way with this
stuff we're going blue
[Music]
this eye looks like it goes yellow red
orange yellow way better than Green if
that's any consolation
that's definitely too much orange
holy moly
for red
and I spray on my eye huh
anybody who needs me I am available
do makeup you'll get your money back
guaranteed
I mean here's what I can say
it is yellow orange and red
I am a little nervous too I think this
is the eyeliner and this comes close to
your eye
you know the problem is I'm not wearing
glasses where I can see anything
oh no
are you supposed to look like a raccoon
sure okay you know it looks better when
your eyes are closed does that matter
Avril Lavigne inspired it's fine okay
top first
visit any YouTube people are looking for
tutorials okay I have to say that that
might be the part that I failed the most
out I'm not saying something wait to the
lashes
I thought maybe I should start putting
on the glasses that help me see what I'm
doing
especially as we get closer to the eyes
that's a good idea this is not mascara
no
this is mascara okay I have no idea what
but I think you just do this
I don't know if I'm even touching your
eyes you are I don't want you to hurt
our eyes she looks down and you put it
on okay
[Music]
Beth stepped in so Kate kept your eyes
I'm loving your uh pit Sweat Right now
you're so nervous
sweating with Whitney Houston in the
crack house
[Music]
that okay now this is the one part that
I was nervous about because we're
putting eyelashes on which means I'm
gonna be glue close to your eyeballs
is that I put
the glue on there and then I put it on
your face
not your face technically my face
I'm really nervous
I like you
I would like you to have fully use of
your eyes
moving forward in your life
and my face is sticky my eyelids are
like sticking
too close to my eyebrows
hmm
it looks like almost
yeah
can't even open my eyes it's fine
yeah it's pretty close
nailed it
nailed that one
okay so Kay has her eyes closed
we're gonna do the big reveal here we go
Kate open your eyes
it's pretty close ready
I mean tell me look at the camera and
tell me which part you take looks the
best
what's what did I get closest
[Applause]
tell me something tell me something
where would you go with your makeup like
this
Hey listen everybody I'm available
put makeup on we'll do this again
I think I'll get better
this was my first time so you have to
come back and we'll try again
okay
Beth said she'd let me cut her hair next
I do his makeup next time huh
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm